Pedro
yeah
and we're back with more live coverage
of the 2016 printers load lip test in
Chicago Jeremy McCarter is next is the
coop Hamilton the revolution
all right good afternoon and welcome
32nd annual Chicago Tribune printers
roll it fast my name is Tom Paschalis
and before we get started with this
program I'd like to thank all of our
sponsors the lit fest is big on social
media the theme of this year's festival
is what's your story so we encourage
everyone to share the stories you hear
this weekend on twitter instagram and
facebook using the hashtag PRL f/16 you
can keep the spirit of wit fest going
all year by downloading the printers ro
app where you'll find all the chicago
tribune premium book contents free and
discounted ebooks for subscribers and
the complete printers roll it fast
schedule if you download today you get a
free ebook and $5 off with fast
merchandise today's program is being
broadcast live on c-span choose book TV
there will be a Q&A session at the end
of the presentation so anyone with
questions please line up at the
microphone to your rights so that the
home viewing audience can hear the
questions lastly before we begin I ask
that you silence all of your cell phones
and turn off any camera flashes with
that I'd like you all to welcome the
co-author of Hamilton the revolution
Jeremy McCarter
hi everybody thank you for being here on
this very hot day my name is Jeremy
McCarter I am very happy to be the
co-author of Hamilton the revolution I
see a couple copies in the audience that
is encouraging as I stand up here I'm
happy to be here here meaning Chicago
here because Chicago is home for the
last two years since I've moved to
Chicago with my family I've had to go
back to New York every time I want to do
something about Hamilton that's where my
co-author when Manuel Miranda has been
that's where the show has been so I'm
sort of the advanced guard here because
as I'm sure you all know in a couple
months
Hamilton is coming here which is very
exciting so to help me get a sense of
who you guys are as we're talking about
this I would love to know who who has
seen Lin's YouTube video from 2009 when
he was at the White House a lot too has
been to New York to see the show some
you guys should be careful this is an
envious looking crowd and who has
listened to the cast album Lots who
listens to the cast album who has heard
it more than once who listens to it once
a week who listens to it every day who
is listen to it once today okay that's a
lot of people some of whom raise their
hand sheepishly you are my people I am
happy you're here thanks for coming so
the organizers asked us to frame these
talks around the theme of the festival
which this year is what's your story
which sounded fun for about five seconds
and then when I started thinking about
that and filling half an hour with that
it got to be really unnerving because if
you think about it what's your story
sounds like a big question about your
life and how do you talk about your life
even if you have a book to talk about
for half an hour and then if you keep
thinking what's actually even more
terrifying than that is what if you can
actually get your whole story in to half
an hour because then what kind of life
are you leading you should quit your
therapist because you're repeating
yourself so what I hope Liz Taylor who's
going to come out to ask some questions
won't mind me doing is tweaking the
theme a little bit instead of talking
about what's your story I would like to
talk about what's our story which is
less fraught for me
and also feels more in keeping with the
theme of this show the thing that we're
all here to talk about which is Hamilton
so well what is our story well obviously
the story that brings us all together
here today is Hamilton and it's not just
us today that this show is bringing
together
Hamilton is as in my experience of being
around at for these last few years the
rare creative work that is bringing an
extraordinary number and range of people
together now that is not always the case
there are plenty of great works that get
made theater film whatever that people
admire in a kind of austere way you
think it's great but you don't want to
give it a hug well people are giving
Hamilton hugs sometimes more than that I
have walked out the stage door plenty of
times on Broadway at the Richard Rogers
where the shows them performing for the
last year and right into the arms of the
enormous crowd that waits to see Leslie
Odom Jr who plays Aaron Burr or Pippa
sue who plays Eliza Schuyler and trust
me from the sound of those shrieks that
is love
we even did Lynn and I did a signing at
the drama book shop in New York a few
blocks from the theater and that was an
incredible afternoon it was a three-hour
procession of young people old people of
every race every color every background
different accents coming up to him and
trying to put into words what this show
had meant to them to their lives and I
won't share them they were really some
of them really really private and
powerful but I will never again doubt
that stories can change the world now we
should stipulate that not everybody
feels this way there are people who for
one principle or another for a simple
matter of taste
you know Hamilton is not for them and
that's okay it doesn't have to be
Universal for us to say that there's
something going on here
this show is having an appeal that spans
political parties and races and ages and
things like that
I asked Questlove about this when I was
doing the book Questlove who was going
to be executive producers of the cast
album said that the this nearly
universal embrace reminded him of
thriller and thrillers the most popular
album ever made he told me that he loved
that album he also said his teachers
love that album
said the kids that had been calling him
racial slurs on the playground before
that album were released suddenly
started asking him to teach them to do
moonwalk and he also said that anybody
else made that comparison he would think
that it were hyperbolic the craziest
thing about Hamilton though is that
we're not just talking about a pop album
that has drawn all this attention even a
super genius pop album that makes
everyone put lots of extra zippers on
their coats the way Thriller did is that
this is a rigorous examination the
founding of the United States it's about
the country and I wouldn't say our
country because I don't want to speak
for you the founders in their time
worked a couple of secular miracles they
defeated the British they founded a
government unlike any government that
has ever existed but these were not
perfect men or perfect women they didn't
end slavery they allowed to thrive you
don't need me to tell you about all the
racial and economic and cultural forces
in the last 200 40 years that have made
plenty of people who live in this
country feel alienated from it the most
important aspect of this whole
phenomenon the thing I tried to talk
about in the book and that I've watched
happen over these last few years is that
Hamilton is making people feel sometimes
for the first time that they have a
stake in the origins of this country
that the story of America
could be their story to how a Broadway
musical did that and what that means for
America that's the story that we tried
to tell in this book and that's what
I'll try to talk about today but to do
that I guess we have to ask the question
what's our story in a slightly different
sense which is what's the story with me
and my co-author and my friend
lin-manuel Miranda so let me take a
minute with that so one night in early
2007 I was the theater critic for New
York magazine and I went to a place way
over on the west side of Manhattan
called 37 arts to see a musical by
people I'd never heard of that I did not
expect to be very good I had been
writing for years repeatedly obnoxiously
sometimes about the power of hip hop as
a way of telling stories I had seen lots
of people try to use hip hop but never
quite in the way that I thought it had
this potential as a way of telling
stories about anything as a kind of
verse drama as the kind of writing that
Shakespeare did and the Greeks did and
Moliere did that most playwrights did
until about 200 years
what I saw instead were a lot of
musicals about how bad the record
industry was which you know is true and
after all these years of waiting
somebody for somebody to act on this to
do the things that I saw my favorite MCS
doing imagine my surprise and my delight
and my relief when within five minutes
of the start of in the heights I felt
like here's someone who gets it this is
someone who actually thinks about these
things the same way that I do someone
who uses hip-hop and salsa to tell a
story about life in Upper Manhattan but
also the thing that's rare has this
incredible facility for writing ballads
who loved the craft of Broadway as much
as he loved Big Pun and Biggie Smalls I
wrote all this down as best I could in
my review and a few weeks later I was
happy to find out that the experience I
had of watching the show how I felt is
about how Lind had felt when he read my
review this sense of oh there's someone
else who gets this thing that I thought
was this eccentric belief the publicist
for the show was a friend of ours he
fixed us up because he thought we would
hit it off clearly he was right in the
summer of 2008 after a performance of M
nights we met up for drinks this was
before Lynn was the MacArthur Foundation
certified genius the People magazine one
of the sexiest men alive but you could
tell that something was coming something
was going on I'd like to give you a
moment-by-moment account of that
conversation because I guess it is
directly responsible for my standing on
this stage right now the fact is we
killed too many brain cells that night
for me to reconstruct it and the most
important is one that I only realized
much later on the opening night of
Hamilton on Broadway in fact I found an
email that I had written a few days
after Lynn and I met for those drinks
and it made clear that in that very
first conversation the summer of 2008 he
told me about this crazy idea he had
that he'd only started to tell a few
people to do a mixtape a concept album
about the life of Alexander Hamilton
told primarily through hip hop that's a
crazy idea
I mean objectively that's a crazy idea
this was a few days before his name is
Mexico vacation when he took round turn
Al's biography with him he clearly had
started to read the book and the
inspiration hit him that fast so fast he
already had the title that night that we
met
then Franklin was a key in a kite it's
image he uses in the show and it applies
to his life at that point fast forward
three years I'm on the artistic staff of
the Public Theater in New York part of
my job there is to bring in artists and
to develop projects that would be right
for public's mainstage season the first
person I proposed to my boss Oskar
Eustis is Lynne he's my friend I say
he's a promising talent a couple years
ago he told me this great idea he got
but as soon as I say Lynne what Oscar
hears is him Lynne he's that guy that
competed against me for the Tony Awards
three years ago and won in the heights
had won Best Musical that year partly at
the expense of a musical that Oscar had
developed so I convinced Oscar to take
the meeting and I emailed land right
away to tell him how thrilled
Oscar was to get to meet him and they
hit it off quickly and completely and I
think for life during one of those early
meetings Lynn handed me a CD kids you'll
have to ask your parents a CD is this
plastic disc that in the old days we
used to hand each other music on I
understand before that it was vinyl but
I don't believe it and an on that CD was
a were the demos of the first eight or
ten songs he had written for Hamilton I
wish I could remember that night when we
met for drinks I remember vividly I
remember precisely what happened when I
heard those songs I was sitting at my
apartment in Brooklyn I popped it in the
third or fourth song on that album was
helpless which if you've heard all you
people who raised your hands
particularly those of you who heard it
this morning you know that helpless is
the song that Eliza Schuyler Hamilton's
soon-to-be wife sings in acts one the
version that you've heard is pretty
close to the one I heard back then the
difference is you here to pursue singing
it I got Linn singing it himself in
falsetto which I treasure for completely
different reasons and I knew at the end
of that song I knew at the end of that
song that if he anyone who could do that
who could write a pop song that was as
catchy and as potent as crazy and love
which the Beyonce jay-z song which
structurally it is and still have that
kind of precise storytelling power to
land it on
listen to it again you see how much
territory covers anybody who's capable
of doing that if you can finish this
project and if you'll put it on stage
instead of making it a record it's going
to be the best musical of our generation
I could tell that on that listen now
that does not mean to say that I
expected all of this the top end around
the show Lin didn't expect it his
director Tommy Kael didn't expect it no
one expected it because again it's
insane no one can even dream you land
the cover of Rolling Stone and the cover
of time and all your heroes want to meet
you and when you go to the White House
the first lady says that the show you
made and I quote is the best piece of
art in any form that I have ever seen in
my life
that CD is important to me for other
reasons too in the context of my
marriage because three years after it
was handed to me we I brought my wife to
opening night at the public and an
intermission she turned to me and said
oh this is why you've been talking about
the show all these years now the party
that night is when Lynn first proposed
the idea that we write the book and
after everything I've said you'd
probably think that my reaction would
have been this immediate sort of
exuberant yes let's go do it my actual
response that night was closer to and
because it was one thing for me to to
see how this incredible show was
developing the work that Lynn and his
director Tommy Kael were doing for
writing a book about it was something
altogether different and what it forced
me to do is ask the question again but
from a different perspective what's our
story meaning what's our angle so the
show exists it's a huge hit people seem
to be embracing it but how do you get
this down on the page it's funny now to
see the capsule descriptions that people
give when they talk about the book they
say things like it's a backstage look at
the show they say it's a companion to
the show and those things are absolutely
true up to a point I mean it's why
people buy the book but those are also
explicitly almost verbatim the things
that we knew it couldn't only be those
are the places where we're starting and
we knew we had to get past this is also
related when I see that it's people say
it's a show of people who it's a book
for people who love Hamilton yeah sure I
mean we intended it to be for people who
have
curiosity about American culture and
American history in hip-hop and things
like that it's just that at the moment
that subset of people is essentially the
same subset as the people who love
Hamilton I went often did some thinking
and I found my also of asking as I
usually do in those moments of
perplexity what would Stephen Sondheim
do it's no exaggeration to say that
Stephen Sondheim's influences on every
page of this book certainly he's an
influence on Lynn as he is an influence
on all composers working in Broadway
today today he's an influence on me
because of how gutsy he is and how
brilliant the chances he takes how
rigorous he is so as I was thinking
about how to do this I was thinking
about his incredible lyric anthology
finishing the Hat
I was thinking about one mantra in
particular that I think is crucial for
all storytellers books songs doesn't
matter he says that content dictates
form and what he means by that is you
figure out the story you want to tell
and that will help you figure out the
form in which you need to tell it so it
occurred to me that if we're going to do
this book we can't just be telling a
story about how the show got made we
want to talk about what the story is
doing what is the change that it is
affecting in the world how is it
changing the lives of the people who
made it and the people who are coming to
see it finally at some point it clicked
and this is the short version from which
this entire book sprang Hamilton doesn't
just dramatize a revolution it is a
revolution it changes the way the
Broadway sounds it changes who gets to
tell the story of the founding and it's
changing the lives of the people making
it and since as Sondheim tells us
content dictates form then it can't have
the same structure as all the other
books about Broadway shows because those
are trying to do something else I can't
have the oral history at the top I can't
have the sidebars with the little
feature apps about people I can't tuck
the libretto away at the back of the
book because those are different pieces
of different stories and it makes it
seem as if the creation of the show was
the end result well in this case we had
to come up with a new structure we had
to make a new kind of book to tell a new
kind of story
what I found we had to do was tell two
stories in tandem there's the show
tracing Alexander Hamilton's incredible
life and then there's the book following
the same arc telling the story of how
the show got made
how to do that well here I turn to
someone I don't consult as often it's on
time but does come in handy from time to
time Jay Z Jay Z's book decoded which I
highly recommend to everybody was a
combination of chapters in which he
talks about his life and songs annotated
songs in which he explains where which
you understand better because of the
chapter that preceded it I thought that
could be a really useful structure if we
can make it chronological we could begin
with the night in 2009 when Lynn
performed the opening number at the
White House the YouTube clip that made
so many of you raise your hands we could
end with opening night on Broadway six
years later when I could already tell at
this point Lynn would probably have just
finished the last numbers in the show so
in between those two well that's the
trick then how to space out the story of
how the show got made the impact that
it's having while Hamilton and the other
characters on stage are going through
their adventures and having their trials
and their crises the final influence on
this on how the book came together and
the thing that really got us rolling was
the Federalist Papers it was a series of
linked essays that figure in the show at
one point that were largely Hamilton's
doing they gave us the idea for the
old-timey titles least my edition of the
Federalist Papers did and they show you
how you can vary a theme and keep
driving a point home they were making
the argument for the Constitution I
wanted to make a argument not exactly on
behalf of the show because the show
didn't need me to argue on its behalf I
mean if there's ever a show that has not
needed someone to throw a lot of nice
adjectives at it at this point it's
Hamilton but I wanted to make an
argument about stories which is relevant
to the same brings us here today I
wanted to make an argument about how
stories can change the world and the
thing that gave me permission to do it
was a quote I found when I was doing
some research Henry Cabot Lodge before
he was the United States Senator edited
the first collection of Hamilton's
papers and he made a point that the
dominant purpose of Hamilton's life was
not creating the National Bank it was
not being a hero of the Revolutionary
War it was certainly wasn't dying in a
duel with Aaron Burr it was creating a
national sentence it was getting this
new people the Americans to think about
themselves in a new way to think about
the country in a new way to think of
themselves
Union and then keep driving that point
home as much as he could while he had
time on this earth now thinking and
feeling that to me might be what
Alexander Hamilton did but thinking and
feeling
that's the theater's wheelhouse I mean
that's our specialty when you get to
change people to feel differently about
themselves that's why we're in business
so when I thought about Alexander
Hamilton's life after reading that quote
I saw what was happening around Lynn
show the enthusiasm the way the people
are reacting so strongly to it I
realized what was really trying to tell
the story of is that they were not two
revolutions they were at two aspects of
the same revolution that's a grandiose
claim to make on behalf of the show to
put it next to the legacy of a founding
father you can make lots of arguments on
behalf of you know sort of this this
moment or that moment about the show's
power here's one for me Buster Ryan's
the rapper came to see it one night he
loved it so much that he told his team
that when he went on stage the next
night for a concert of his own he wanted
to have a costume like the one the king
wears in Hamilton when you can send bus
the bus on stage dressed as King George
the third you have stretched the limits
of the possible two aspects of one
American Revolution that's a story we
were going to tell and what we would
soon be calling in Hamilton so how did
we do it well we had to work really fast
not quite Alexander Hamilton fast
because no one is that fast but we had
to work at least as fast as the people
that Lynn collaborated with to make this
show now they're coming to town you
might get to spend time with them so
it's worth saying that should warn you
that Tommy Cale the director Alex lakum
or the music director and Andy blanking
peeler the choreographer the sort of
core or member artist who made this show
if you're seeing them are you going to
talk to them caffeinate in advance
caffeinate heavily because they think
fast
they talk fast they even move pretty
fast the creative metabolism of the
people who made this show is light speed
and that's one of the things that's
essential it's why it works there are 32
chapters in the book I had about seven
weeks to draft them I do not recommend
this as a way of making books for the
record there was a head start of me
having been around a lot to see things
that were happening in rooms where no
writer belongs but then I was in
there is a writer I was there someone on
the artistic staff of the Public Theatre
Lynn couldn't have had much longer than
I did to write to 200 plus annotations
that are in this book he was doing this
while he was performing seven times a
week and unbeknownst to everybody was
writing the music for the cantina scene
in the new Star Wars I would send him
PDF files with the sort of digital
sticky notes attached asking questions
pointing out places in lyrics where I
remembered there once having been a
variation on something trying to figure
out why he made the choice that he made
and he surprised me again and again as
well as I knew the guy he surprised me
by digging into his past his life
showing me things in the in the show
that were more autograph / graphical
than I ever expected
he was my first reader and I was his and
what we contributed to the book but
that's how it had to be on our crazy
timetable to make these pieces snap
together to tell one story which was the
goal even then towards the end of this
process we had to step up the pace even
more we wanted to add scans of his
notebooks if you look through the book
there's some of my favorite things in it
you can see the actual pages where this
stuff is coming off his brain and he's
trying to get it down on the page well
the only way to find the right pages to
use was for him before he went on stage
one night to leave me with a big stack
of those notebooks which is an
unvarnished look into the guy's brain
and I had the same feeling I had to get
him to see things more quickly than I
could deliver the finished chapters so
finally I ended up just sharing the
Dropbox folder where I was working on my
pages where I was writing my chapters
which you know I've don't let anybody
see that stuff I don't let my editors
see that stuff but it was the only way
we were going to get it done if we
weren't on the same wavelength we never
would have started the book and if we
didn't trust each other we never could
have finished it there was no help
coming from other writers but then we
didn't want help from other writers on
this it didn't feel like we wanted
outside experts weighing in again
content dictates form if the story of
Hamilton is a story of lots of different
kinds of people from different
backgrounds coming together to make
something together then when the
challenge was to get the most different
kinds of content the most different
episodes essays profiles things like
that
fit them into the smallest number of
pieces so no sidebars no things hanging
off the side unless their primary
sources gchat an email exchange cut
lyrics from the show historical
documents now content dictates form is
the Sondheim principle but there's also
something that we took from the spirit
of the show itself Tommy kale the show's
brilliant director realized early on
that the only way this works is not to
apologize for the fact that he has
broken with all you know convention and
made the actors who were playing these
roles primarily actors of color and what
he says is either the audience is going
to come up to you or they're not but
there's not going to be a wink at the
audience it's going to be immediate it's
going to be unfiltered the book like the
show is something that we wanted to have
you be only a millimeter away from the
action and the weeks of writing this
last summer being the perspective
perspective of being the eyewitness to
something incredible was not a stretch
Tommy was brilliant at fine-tuning the
show but he was at least as brilliant in
creating the conditions that allowed his
collaborators to thrive now that's a
very delicate thing to do you're talking
about the psychology of 40 or 50 people
and you're trying to give them what they
need that they can do their best even if
it's not always the same from one to the
next
he kept everybody cool he made the cast
and the designers think the stakes were
low that they could play and take
chances and I would believe this for as
long as I stayed in the Richard Rogers
theatre during tech and then I would
walk outside and into total pandemonium
because as the show got closer to its
opening that on Broadway the fever in
New York kept building it was a
hurricane around the show and Tommy had
created an eye the audience reaction at
that first performance on Broadway it
was so crazed but some of the actors
weren't sure they were going to get
through it afterwards on stage they all
rally together and some of them were
crying this is going to sound a little
exploitative but if you want to know why
it was important to tell the story the
way we told it that crying that the
actors were doing was as important to us
as the fact that the show happened on a
certain date in a certain theatre and it
was received in a certain way
the reason why Hamilton is a historical
drama that feels so immediate it feels
as if it's happening to people that we
know is because when Lin and Tommy
talked about story the capital T capital
as the story of the show they never just
meant facts on a timeline what they
meant is that they wanted to create they
wanted to evoke the emotional reality of
these men and women who lived in the
1770s and 80s and 90s the room where it
happens the great second act showstopper
is not about the dinner I wish Hamilton
and Madison and Jefferson traded the
location of the US Capitol for a
National Bank it's a song about how Burr
feels about the fact that he is excluded
from that dinner his envy and his anger
when Lin dramatizes the pressure of
needing to put the new nation on his
feet he doesn't write about politics at
all he writes about fatherhood
dear Theodosia is the ballad that
Hamilton and burr sing to their infant
children so it's not just in the book
that Lin added a song or that Tommy
found an actor we wanted to show how it
felt that meant we got to see a lot of
beautiful things I got to write about
them but also met some really painful
things there are personal achievements
here and their dreams coming true
there's also sickness there's also death
a lot of pain happened in a couple years
that we are trying to retell in the
course of this book so sure on one hand
we're writing for fans now we want
people who love the show to have a
better sense of what it is they're
hearing listening to but we were also
aware of writing for people who are
going to look back on this many years
from now we want them to know how Lynn
and Tommy and they're brilliant
collaborators do it did it but he also
want them to know how it felt to be
doing it we also most of all want them
to know what it cost this idea of
looking back from some place in the
future is important to understand this
moment I think the story that we're
telling is one that started before us
and it's going to continue after us
there are a couple of moments in the 8
years that I was very privileged to
watch this show happen when I had this
feeling that I can only like him to
vertigo but in time instead of in space
this historical vertigo of the scene the
past and the present crashed together
it's hard to write about this stuff
without sounding like you're high trust
me because I've tried to do it
when we learned the President Obama was
going to come to the show it was
technically after we were supposed to be
done writing it but when President Obama
is going you know you cracked your
laptop open again and we add an epilogue
to see President Obama walk on stage at
the Richard Rogers after a performance
of the show
the team stand about six feet from where
Chris Jackson who plays George
Washington had just sung the words of
Washington's farewell address then to
hear President Obama look back on the
incidents of his own administration was
to see past and present starting to
shimmer next to each other and the
distance between them to collapse the
biggest moment of this kind of course it
happened after the book went to press
when I was very very lucky to go with
the Hamilton company to the White House
and to see them perform for president
and mrs. Obama vice president mrs. Biden
and an incredible array of dignitaries
in the East Room and I can only thank
the theater gods I didn't have to try to
write about that on a book deadline
because I would have sounded Rocky
Mountain High on that one there's one
tableau in particular I want to leave
you with I tried to write about it in an
essay for BuzzFeed about this but if you
want to understand what's special about
this show I think it's in here the last
song that they did that day was one last
time this is the song in which Chris
Jackson sings the words of Washington's
farewell address now imagine this you're
seeing Chris Jackson who is an African
American man from Cairo Illinois singing
this song directly in front of him is
President Obama who is african-american
and his wife behind him is the Gilbert
Stuart portrait of George Washington the
first president the character that Chris
Jackson is playing who owned black men
and all of a sudden it felt like all of
American history was condensed into this
one little tableau I didn't even have to
turn my head to see it what's most
exciting to me about this show is
knowing the people who were sitting just
behind President Obama when this
performance was happening there were a
hundred students from local schools
there's a chapter in the book where I
talk about what some of these students
some of the reactions they were feeling
when in earlier performances when
students had come but
the place where the two revolutions
intersect the place where the Alexander
Hamilton impulse for union and this
shows extraordinary appeal start running
together is that those kids sitting
there were seeing two George
Washington's and they're both valid the
Gilbert Stuart Washington meant
something in the 1790s when it was
painted the lin-manuel Miranda Chris
Jackson Washington means something now
in 2016 when I spoke to the actors when
I was making the book the most powerful
interviews I did or with actors like
Leslie Odom Jr who plays Burr and daveed
Diggs who plays Jefferson and they were
very candid with me about how their
lives might be different if when they
were the age of those kids they had seen
a black man playing George Washington or
if they had had the opportunity to step
into the shoes of these men who had felt
remote from their experience it felt
like they were living a story that they
had nothing to do with well this is the
last generation of kids who won't at
least have the chance to have that
experience because of this show Lynne
has reimagined the past in writing a
historical drama that works the way this
one does but he's also a prostitute the
future we know that in 20 years this
will be a much different country than it
is today
we know that the racial makeup of the
country is changing we know that the
expectations about what it means to be
an American are going to change what's
exciting to me as I think about how this
is a chapter in one long American story
is that Hamilton like the Obama
presidency are both in a sense a
prefiguration of what's to come the book
was published on April 12 and the two
months since then the best reactions
I've gotten have been along the lines of
I had no idea it was that hard people
didn't know quite how much effort and
toil went in to making this thing that
looks I think you'd agree pretty
effortless it seems though it was
natural it was bound to be what it was
of course that's not true and is once
you step back a little and look at it
you realize there's a lesson here think
of the story that I've been telling
today think of how many fluky little
thing is said to happen just right at
just the right time for me and Lynn to
meet or become friends let alone write
this book together think of the show it
seems perfect and inevitable but it
wasn't anymore
than the book was Tommy told me
something few days before opening night
it's a great insight into this process I
wish I'd been able to use into the book
but you get the benefit of it today he
said he was looking back over this whole
process
he said if Flynn had really shanked that
performance at the White House back in
2009 what would have happened it's
lawless he rips it it could have gone
sideways so many different ways and it
didn't the amount of things that had to
conspire for any of this to happen to
make it make it more a miracle than
anything else if the book wasn't
inevitable if the show wasn't inevitable
then what does that imply about the
subject of both of those things which is
the American Revolution of the 18th
century
Hamilton's revolution well it seems like
that must not be inevitable either the
Americans had to win the war something
that no colonist had ever done they had
to found a government that had no real
precedent in world history no one had
done that either and they somehow to
make them both stick knowing that we
take the show success for granted and
shouldn't makes me want to stop taking
the American experiment for granted - it
could have failed at any moment it's
still mine we really do need to do what
the show says which is to look around
and feel how lucky we are to be alive
right now if as this show is helping us
to see maybe we're all part of the
American story
then all of us have a role to play
making sure it continues one of the last
things that Lynne and I added to this
book was my very favorite page of the
288 between those covers it's the
dedication page among other things is
the most perfect collaboration on the
book because it's two lines long and I
had the first line which was why don't
we dedicate this book to our children
and he had the second line which is
because it's Lynne perfect and it was
who will come of age with our young
nation now that line on one hand is two
fathers expressing their hopes for their
young son and daughter but it's also two
Americans expressing the same kind of
hope for the country so what I'd like to
do now a couple minutes before we start
taking questions is read a chapter from
the book this is one that touches on
some of these things it is chapter 14
those of you who have I don't think
anyone should read along
that would be creepy I mean if you
insist keep me honest if I drop a word
or something don't do that please don't
do that this is chapter 14 this is about
the American experiment and when it
really began this is the chapter that
sets up the songs that are the final
battles of the Revolutionary War guns
and ships history has its eyes on you
and Yorktown in title of the chapter is
on Paul Tazewell and the faction of
revolution this is a day of firsts said
Tommy it was May 9th 2014 and he was
looking up at the hundred fifty people
who packed the top four theater of the
52nd Street project a program that
specializes in plays created for and by
kids and sometimes offer space to shows
like Hamilton they had come for what he
called quote the first time we will have
ever done the first act and second act
back to back going for a laugh he said
you're the first audience in the history
of the world to have seen that the
show's title was another first that day
Jeffrey seller the lead producer had
persuaded Lynch drop mixtape from the
title a few months earlier he joked that
it might be the most important
contribution he made to the show quote
Hamilton sounds like a blockbuster
Jeffrey says at least it does now Tommy
warned the audience that Lynn had been
adding and changing things until the
night before quote you'll be hearing
things that not even he has heard out
loud
he said Lynn couldn't can't help himself
finishing a tune at 10:30 for actors who
are learning it at 11:00
he had tweeted during a workshop the
previous fall horrible horrible when
will I stop doing my homework on the bus
I'm 33
the company has spent five weeks
experimenting with different ways to
move people and furniture around the
stage five weeks was an unusually long
time but not nearly long enough to
figure out how to stage this show Tommy
had been feeling stressed out about how
to speed up this process when lack alex
lack and more the music director
reminded him that nobody was forcing
them to do anything
Tommy realized he was right they decided
to stage act 1 and fall back to music
stands for act 2
but the biggest first of that workshop
and its real revelation was what the
cast wore looking back now the costume
choices of Hamilton seemed obvious
nobody thought so in May 2014 not even
the man who made them in 20 years on
Broadway Paul Tazewell had designed
costumes for show set in the distant
past like the color purple and dr.
Zhivago and our own time like magic bird
and in nights when he had heard Lynn's
demos he knew that Hamilton would need
to combine both sensibilities but as
with David Korins scenic design the
question was how quote the challenge was
figuring out where those two eras meet
and what percentage of this world is tip
hop and what percentage is 18th century
Paul says he looked at a lot of street
fashion from our time and John
Trumbull's paintings from Alexander
Hamilton's time he studied the work of
fashion icons who had tried to mash up
the two eras jean-paul Gaultier
Alexander McQueen John Galliano
everybody has ripped on in 18th century
at one time or another he says in spite
of his experience his well-stocked
toolkit and that formidable pile of
research Paul couldn't locate the right
podium intersection between past and
present luckily he and Tommy had
collaborated on five productions before
this developing enough mutual trust to
remain untroubled by the fact that they
weren't sure what to do quote we thought
the only way to figure this out is to
try it says Paul since they knew what
the cast looked like in contemporary
clothes because that's what the actors
wore to rehearsal every day Paul used
the workshop to experiment with an
intensely authentic hit design period
from the neck down modern from the neck
up became the rule quote I didn't want
Chris to be in a powdered wig as
Washington says Paul I wanted to see him
for who he was that choice by itself
didn't constitute first Joe Papp started
putting black and Latino actors in
period costumes for his free Shakespeare
production
more than half a century ago more
recently visual artists such as Ken
Hindu Wylie someone whose work Paul
consulted during his research had
painted contemporary black men in the
trappings of old master portraits still
the sight of this cast in Paul's
costumes made the show seem doubly
triply audacious the biggest jolt came
toward the end of act 1 when he actors
came on stage wearing coats blue coats
with red trim and black brass buttons
unmistakeably the uniforms of George
Washington's Continental Army that day
for the first time a hundred-fifty
audience members had the mind-altering
experience of watching black and Latino
actors young men and women from
communities that have seen their freedom
and fringed for hundreds of years when
freedom for us all people wept at
intermission they screamed at the finale
in the cramped Lobby afterwards you
could hear a potent clatter of emotions
euphoria disbelief desperation this
lasts from people who wanted to invest
in the show there were four
presentations between Thursday and
Saturday which meant that 600 people
fanned out that weekend to tell their
friends what they had seen by Monday
Hamilton had become the most talked
about not quite show in New York for
Tommy the experience of put an
experiment of putting actors in period
costumes had been a complete success one
choice that it seemed like a concession
to the sparrow nature of workshops
putting all of the actors in parchment
toned clothes and adding colors only
when they distinguished themselves as
specific characters carried all the way
to Broadway Paul was delighted by the
outcome too he had received five Tony
Award nominations in his career but
still wanted badly to get this one right
this piece is so humbling
he says tears rising in his eyes I
really didn't want to f it up and get in
the way of it there are certain places
where it resonates where I remember oh
yeah I'm a part of this not this
production I know what I bring to this
production but being an American I am a
part of it as opposed to being he
searched for the right word and
afterthought
when the Battle of Yorktown sequence
ended that day the largely black and
Latino caste singing a song written by a
Puerto Rican composer wearing costume
selected by an african-american designer
climbed on top of boxes and chairs to
celebrate having done the impossible
and II blanking Bueller would spend the
next 16 months trying to recapture how
exhilarating the moment felt it took him
until a week before opening it on
Broadway to feel that he succeeded thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was wonderful thanks so much I'll
ask a few questions and please start
getting up at the microphones and think
of your own just we're talking about the
observing this is an important cultural
moment the play revolutionised theater
the book which is just extraordinarily
beautiful record for revolutionised
bookmaking but Jeremy had it
revolutionize you wow that's a big
question I guess it's a big question
what like I said at the end towards the
end there it really does make me think
with more concern and more loyalty about
the United States of America I think a
chapter that I'd initially wanted to
read about this that hit some of these
being slightly differently but was just
way too long is the one that makes the
point that you can look at the founders
and how you sort of needed all of them
in exactly the right positions at
exactly the right time to get the United
States to be formed in the way that it
was and it's exactly the same way is
when the guys who made the show had to
be in exactly the right place the right
time to do it
I think once you start looking at things
that way look at the how contingent all
these things are it makes you treasure
what you got because you know how
tenuous a lot of it can be so that's
been on my mind a lot and also you know
the one experience of this that I didn't
have the whole time I was watching all
my friends go through this insanity I
mean you know
daveed Diggs and oak who plays Madison
and all these guys who who had very
different lives and very different
careers before the show well when you
get that famous it changes your life a
lot I've been watching the big spotlight
swing around to them one after another
but I'd only been watching but when this
book came out the adoration
the show suddenly the spotlights on the
book - and then I realized actually I
had no idea what that felt like I had
watching them I never could have guessed
the sort of that that like love that
intensity of affection that people have
for the show I just can't really
understand it until it's a Tillich's
chasing you down 46th Street so I
actually have a question that was texted
to me a few minutes ago by a 7th grader
I don't know if she's in the audience or
not but Ilana and Neuberger if you're
here seventh grader
she writes could your words be is
eloquently put about politics today or
another time in history or is there
something that stands out about the
story of Hamilton that made the book so
beautiful
well the stakes were higher right in the
1770s and 80s I mean it really was a
question of life or death for those
characters if the Revolution was going
to work and if they would be able to
make it last you know the stakes are
still high today so it would be a little
trickier I suppose to find that kind of
subject but I you know I think the
fundamentals of the storytelling in
Hamilton how rigorous Lynne and Tommy
were and got all their collaborators to
be about telling the story I think you
know just for me as a person who who you
know writes and puts projects together
just watching how this little other
question about artistic form that I will
not bore you with today but hit me up at
the table outside I'll tell you about it
but this idea that that the content
dictates form principle and what how
that really works in practice you know
if you get that right then you can find
subjects anywhere and you can make them
say great so I was talking a little bit
earlier as a third grade teacher at in
the audience and she was saying is
there's some explicit lyrics in this but
she's thinking about how to sort of
bring it into her classroom so do you
have any thoughts on that yeah this is
going to teach a whole generation of
kids how to swear
there are already moments when my wife
and I are listening with our daughter
that we've learned we now instinctively
sort of start going a lot of various
points as she doesn't quite hear what
Hercules Mulligan is saying at the end
of Yorktown we'll get there I I don't
know I don't know exactly what level of
you know foul mouthed eloquence is right
for what ages but I will say the Jeffrey
seller the producer of the show has made
a really admirable commitment to making
sure that students get to see it in New
York funding came from the Rockefeller
Foundation in a program with a syllabus
that was assembled by the Gilder Lehrman
Institute of American history to make
sure that I think it's 20,000 students a
year high school students we get to come
see the show from the kinds of schools
that they probably wouldn't have been
going to see Broadway shows otherwise
that to me I mean when we put revolution
on the cover of this book you know
people can you know if anyone is
skeptical of that claim as I would have
been skeptical of the claim if I hadn't
gone through this over the last few
years that to me is the last line of
defense
I know the experience those kids have
been having I've talked to their
teachers I've seen it the world is going
to be a different place because of what
comes out of those kids brains as a
consequence of having seen this show
here we have a question hi I just want
to say to start off I'm huge Hamilton
fan listen to the cast recording I think
the week before it came out on NPR
turned my dad into a Broadway fan so
good things coming on this direction but
what I find most amazing about the book
that you wrote revolution in the musical
and the characters as the musical is
about if it's the right people at the
right place at the right time and can
you imagine the American Revolution is
George Washington wasn't in his place in
his career at that time what is also
amazing is that this cast this diverse
cast is telling the story of the
founding fathers when every day on the
news we hear about diversity problems
that we still have in the 21st century
so my question is do you think that
Hamilton could have been successful on
Broadway if it had come out
10-15 years ago with the cast that it
has now I don't know I don't know I mean
to imagine a world to imagine it's a
great question I mean I don't want and I
don't answer it too quickly ten years
ago is 2006 you know there was a great
songs I think great songs I think the
fact that he has channeled all the power
all the the stuff that we love about
really great pop music into telling a
story with this kind of precision and
rigor I think that's probably going to
work any time now would it have been a
huge phenomenon any other time then that
I don't know I mean how important was it
the Michelle Obama came to see it at the
public and freaked out about how much
she loved it or that Barack Obama was
our president right exactly that's what
I mean like the fact that it is so
coincident with the Obama administration
seems important to me and it's hard to
imagine it otherwise and and in terms of
its in terms of how it intersects with
the news there is at least one moment
when that intersection was really close
together as it happened the company went
back into rehearsal after the run
downtown and before they reopened on
Broadway well right ask right the night
before they reassembled was the shooting
in Charleston when the white
supremacists opened fire and killed nine
worshippers at the church and it was in
the room the next day Chris Jackson who
plays Washington and I talked about it
it was very difficult thing for him to
be standing there singing this new song
that Lynn had just written about
Washington's hopes for a country where
everyone would would be safe and no one
would make them afraid knowing that
these nine people had just been killed
of what ought to be the safest sanctuary
that we have you know Tony Kushner has
talked about this because Tony keeps
writing these plays that seem prophetic
somehow you know he writes a show that
begins with the line there is no
Underground in Louisiana there's only
underwater and then Hurricane Katrina
happens like how does that happen and
his answer is if you write about the
world we live and if you write about
politics if you write about government
write about society in a really
disciplined way
then you're much likelier to have things
that intersect with the news and I think
that's the case here
I mean Lin could have pulled a lot of
punches and he didn't pull them thank
you very much
and since no one else is asking a
question I want to know what you're
doing for the Tony I will be at the
Hamilton Tony party I know how you know
I'll be watching the screen and crossing
my fingers and drinking champagne why
we're having this program on Saturday
Saturday program out of favor anybody
else out there so here comes one well
she's coming up so what about the
historians have you had it any
historians who sort of like quibble say
with your boots the take on say Aaron
Burr or any of the others there is an
interesting case because he is as Lynn
had something in the show he's of course
one of the great villains of history now
Lynn thinks more kindly of burr than
almost anybody I am aware of certainly
more kindly about the guy than say Ron
chernow who wrote the book that inspired
Lynn to write the show you know there
Lynn Lynn said to Ron turnout when he
first asked turnout to help him as a
kind of consultant on the show he didn't
say I want historians to like it he said
I want historians to take it seriously
and what that means is if you're a
historian and you want things to be
taken seriously then you pull on it you
push on it you challenge it you look for
the weak the ways that it's argument is
weak or strong you fit it into the
context of the conversation that's
already going on you know there are
historians who wish that Lynn had
written things differently or fault him
for this or that to me it's the fact
that there is a genuine historical
dialogue happening about a Broadway
musical is one of the most science
fictiony things about this whole of
science fiction experience it does
absolutely transcend time you just don't
what period you're in when you're
watching it or when you're listening
great questions what do you think made
Hamel
and so such a popular musical as opposed
to let's say advice even though it
shares so many of the same musical
styles that's another really great
question it because it's the same team
Jeffrey seller produced both shows Lynne
wrote both you to co-author on a night
same choreographer same music director a
couple of the same actors and Tommy
directed both so what happens well one
thing for sure is he matured as an
artist I think partly they all did they
had one under their belts at that point
they were able to deepen what they could
each of them could do and what
collectively they did and you know this
is my sort of pet theory that neither of
the two gentlemen involved quite sees as
crucial as I do but another thing that
happened between Heights and Hamilton is
that Lynne did two shows with Stephen
Sondheim he appeared in a production
merrily we roll along at the Encore
series so he was he was he was doing
Sondheim lyrics on stage and he did the
Spanish language translations of the
Sharks lyrics for a revival on Broadway
so again it's not just that he's sitting
there studying these things or talking
to Sondheim about it he's got to put
them in his brain and do something with
them I mean there is to me a sense that
Sondheim is the is the is the sort of
proto hip-hop figure of Broadway because
if you listen to the precision and the
and the and the density of what he's
doing with his lyrics
I mean emcees would kill to write a song
like chrysanthemum tea from Pacific
overtures which if you know it is just
the most sort of wonderful playful
clever string of of rhymes so I think
it's partly that and then you know and
it's that so that's about what's
happening on stage but what's happening
offstage everything else you know
lightning strikes sometimes I think it
just had to be everything lining up
exactly right and it did it just happens
almost never but this time it did
hi come on up hi
thank you for your talking was very
interesting I have a comment and a
question
my comment is that I'm old enough old to
remember when hair open up on Broadway
and I remember thinking wow this is my
music these are my people singing and
that's the very same way I felt about
Hamilton that this is going to be so
important to these kids because it's
their show it's their music my question
however is exactly how much time did you
spend with the show itself before you
started writing the book literally in
the theatre with the actors with these
characters with the staff right let's
see some of the episodes that are in the
book are things that are written from my
direct observation like Renee Lee's
Gold's Barry's callback I wasn't Colin
when everyone in the room was freaking
out about how great she was I saw I
watched that happen about let's see some
of the I can't remember what I wrote now
it's hard to say I was in script
meetings I was in design meetings I was
the chapter 16 the one about tech week
at the public how difficult that was
because it was so complicated I was in
the room watching them try to deal with
the fact that they didn't have enough
time to do what they needed to do and
then once I knew I was going to write
this book about it then I just started
showing up as much as I could get back
to New York
because I knew that at any moment
something important might happen that
I'd want to preserve and sure enough
there are these great moments like when
Lynn heard the room where it happens the
showstopper for the first time in a
Broadway theater which if you think
about it the way he's always imagined it
and his very funny very profane reaction
to that he was sitting right there when
that happens so you know it's always
like if I'd known in in 2011 that I was
going to be writing a book about it I
would have taken better notes instead of
just trying to pick this up on the fly
in the summer of 2015
thank you
hi thank you so much for your talk and
your wonderful book and this incredible
incredible musical one of the things I
love about Hamilton is the really strong
female characters and I was wondering if
you and Lynn are considering any future
projects where the strong female
characters are not only the wives wives
of the really prominent men who were
involved in history but are the people
who are making history themselves that's
right well Lynn's very next project in
fact is Moana
it's a Disney film with a female
protagonist that he has just been I
think finishing the songs for that will
be out later this year so yes absolutely
in terms of our collaborations I mean
you know his next project I don't know
if I'll work with the guy and I mean it
was fun I hope we'll get to but he's got
that and my next I'm working on a book
now that I'm trying to finish and one of
the protagonists of that it's a book
about young American radicals from World
War one and one of my protagonists is
alex paul who was the absolutely
fearless incredibly inspiring
suffragists leader who helped get this
susan b anthony amendment across the
finish line oh one more question
oh hi everything I've read about Lynn or
CN is Twitter even that just seems like
his pace is just so frantic and almost
like non-stop like in Hamilton and in
one part of the book it says someone
like asked him are you ever going to
slow down you write like you're running
out of time and he said well I am do you
share that sort of same work ethic as
him or was it kind of hard to keep up
with his pace as you were working with
someone who just literally never stopped
it we do kind of share the same work
ethic I mean we both sort of had I mean
we had we had a choice to hit this
deadline that they'd set for us we had
to keep churning out words as fast as we
could but but you know Lynne is a very
rare specimen I have gotten to work with
a lot of very talented people and
there's something unique about that guy
about how closely he listens the things
he picks up that you don't think he's
picking up
the speed that his brain is moving all
the time even when you think it's not it
comes out when he does improv he's part
of a freestyle hip-hop team and he's the
best at it he's funny and he comes up
with these things that are moving so
yeah you know you sort of have to be on
your toes when you're with the guy but
he's also a friend and so that's part of
the you know one of the things I love
about the guy is that it just it never
stops I mean thank God because if it
stopped look I mean maybe we wouldn't
have Hamilton yeah thank you well I have
to say that everything that Jeremy just
said about Lynne I would say about
Jeremy
really he is remarkable and I'm so
honored to know him and that he is here
to tell our story so thank you very much
[Applause]
and Jeremy will be signing books these
beautiful beautiful books right outside
Thanks and thank you once again on
behalf of the printers roll it Fest you
can find out more information and give
us your feedback at printers roll it
Fest org thank you
[Music]
yeah
and
Oh
[Music]
and
yeah
that was Jeremy McArthur co-author of
Hamilton the revolution book TV is live
this weekend from the printers roll it
fest in Chicago Seymour Hersh was
scheduled to present next but was unable
to make it he'll be on book TVs
afterwards program on July 9th and 10th
to discuss his book the killing of Osama
bin Laden
for more information on that interview
visit book tv.org
the next panel from printers roll it
Fest is scheduled to start around 4:00
p.m. Eastern it's a conversation between
adam cohen author of imbeciles and amy
goodman author of democracy now while we
wait for that to begin we want to show
you an interview with Congressman Tom
Cole he sat down with book TV to talk
about the books that have influenced his
life and career